ariel on va rester dans les femmes et
l'amour on va faire une interview par
amour
[Musique]
à jan van baal est ce que par amour
comme si si vous présenteriez des
maîtresses à votre mari
eh bien écoutez je ne sais pas mais si
c'était le seul moyen de le garder
peut-être que je le ferai que ce beau
mais régulièrement non mais vide alors
là je vais une réponse
[Musique]
oh que c'est beau mega man je voudrais
toujours être la favorite
enfin j'en rêverai je prierai hélas
je te laisse penser
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
cacher quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer ah
ben ça bien sûr le cacher oui bien sûr
bien sûr à ce problème a même aucun
problème et je dirais même m'avait même
nom mais je dirais même que c'est moi
qui l'ait tué harry mais on le sait
magnifique qu'il a une chance d'être
mère c'est le plus veinard de la bande
et jean qui est ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à vous mettre à la drogue
ou l'arrêter
cela je dirais que je serai tout pour
d'abord en dissuader lundi 10 mai mais
je crois que par amour ou on est prêt à
tout d'ailleurs moi je me souviens voyez
dans dans mon enfance où j'habitais le
mexique alors
je me rappelle que mon père avait fait
prendre des champignons hallucinogènes à
ma mère est donc finalement oui bien sûr
je ne fais pas une mycose
et donc il est l'heure elle avait essayé
donc et je crois que lui avait fait un
trait merveilleux voyage de champignons
hallucinogènes et elle par amour avait
suivi et je pense que ça c'était assez
mal passé pour elle voilà est-ce que par
amour vous feriez la laisser marianne
à votre avis est-ce que par un mot vous
seriez prête à prendre 17 kg
oui bien sûr mais bon si bernard henri
penser si bernard au rite en qui rigole
ça va mais
nommés mais s'il avait envie tout à coup
d'une femme atreg voilà un beau zéro
mauvaise eh bien je prendrai les 17 clos
mais je crois que c'est formidable mais
j'avais vu amiral j'avais vu quand même
à quel point les allées et dévoué à son
âme ou mais merde
je suis pas sûr que que fait
l'adaptation féminine qui est
extraordinaire ariel est ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à vivre avec
bernard et la maîtresse que vous lui
auriez présenter je sais pas j'ai j'ai
connu un cas où
un homme
vivait en effet avec sa femme
et sa maîtresse mais n'ont qu'a voulu
dire proche proche de vous oui des gens
connus
non mais attends que des gens proches de
vous sérieusement en réalité un moment
donné
bon je juge habiter le mexique et et mon
père était un très grand séducteur cover
très beau très beau et un moment donné
mais j'étais très enfants est très petit
alors je ne suis pas sûr j'ai capté des
choses mais peut-être pas vraiment mais
il y avait une femme qui était la
dernière se disait la dernière
descendante du dernier empereur aztèque
qui s'appelait saute schild qui était
une ravissante métisse aux cheveux tous
tirés en arrière
extraordinairement belle et qui habitait
chez moi au dessus de ma chambre
d'ailleurs et ma mère était vivante et
donc je me suis toujours posé des
question de comment est ce que cette
femme vivait à nous poser votre mère l'a
accepté ça en fait je ne sais pas et
donc est ce que moi je serai capable je
sais pas mais tout ça est en même temps
vous savez très très douloureux c'est
parce que on était très amoureuse quand
même bien sûr bah oui c'est bien tout
l'idée de cette interview c'est par
amour est-ce que par amour par exemple
vous seriez prête à vendre votre corps
si bernard henri lévy vous le demandez
à des qualités intentions alors je
dirais d'abord je ne suis pas achetable
ouais ah non quand on aura dit le prix
quel prix ni mettrait la banane
est ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
ne pas faire l'amour pendant trois ans
alors
commence maintenant je
tombe ça c'est terrible parce qu'en
effet mais vous voyez quand on lit les
grands mystiques toi-même et saufs juana
inés de la cruz
par exemple la fin je pense qu'on arrive
à un certain plaisir dans l'abstinence
aussi maîtrise pas ce qu'on appelle oui
et je pense qu'il ya une forme d'extase
aussi de désiré et de se dire non je
suis plus fort que mon désir je ne le
cèdent pas je reste comme ça on maîtrise
de moi-même trois ans real quand même
oui je sais c'est qu'ils peuvent aller
moi non mais mais mais peut-être qu'on
arrive à une sorte de forme d'extase de
douleur ou alors tu peux passer en
manuel non
j'y reviens ou doute vous croyez vous à
ça vous voyez ce qu'elle dit là que
l'abstinence amène à l'extase amiral ça
serait quand même ça peut être une
satisfaction nous ne sommes pas des
animaux voilà si si nous sommes des
manigances pas ça du tout le sera
peut-être des mammifères ne sommes pas
des animaux ils ont fermé on peut aussi
simplement fantasme est très très fort
et on est dans une sorte de rêve éveillé
dans l'imaginaire et avoir une sorte de
forme d'extase comme un des champignons
toujours
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu